clink fine fine thank you welcome
everyone back to there's really bad guys
clink it up pick it up and clink it up
we are back with another episode this
episode is brought to you by tipsy elves
the place that sells these amazing
onesies that you probably can't even see
mine because mine is green I totally
didn't even think of it blue it I
ordered a green onesie and I forgot that
we have a green screen so you can see
mine there give you hers open amazing
just unzip the top because I don't want
to be just invisible for the whole
podcast look at mine look how cute okay
so why don't you talk about the build
quality just for one sec um I've had
lots of Lyndsey's in the past like
costume onesies like the ones that are
shaped like animals are usually like big
and comfortable yeah but any onesie that
is marketed towards being like a
comfortable onesie sweatshirt material
kind of onesie they're always like way
too tight yeah this like I wanted onesie
that like is lounge lounge sighs you
know and I mean yeah the fit is
impeccable the the quality of materials
is amazing nice Osen not too tight like
everywhere no it's a mate we'll get
we'll tell you guys more about this in
the middle of podcast but right now if
you go to tipsy elves calm and enter
jayjay at checkout you can have 20% off
site-wide
and they don't only have onesies they
have really fun course Christmas
sweaters they have Christmas Day
literally a Christmas sweater with beer
pong cups it's really fun it's amazing
they have really really fun holidays I
think Julian did when he put his on was
zip it all the way up zip zip it up yeah
but I've been wearing this all weekend
it's amazing so John in last week's
video yeah those guys yeah I know I'm
terrified of other people's that they on
my [ __ ] like this good yeah
so thank you to tipsy elves our other
sponsor and I am so unbelievably excited
to have them as our sponsor on the
podcast is Stan's socks I don't know how
many of you guys know what it's David
what these are but Stan's
makes the best
Ochs in the entire they are my favorite
socks I've ever touched I've ever looked
at the socks a lot of times can be
dismissed as kind of I'd rather not get
socks as a gift that is the opinion of
someone who's never touched Stan's socks
Stan's is the uncommon thread they
believe that they can make an artistic
statement with their socks and I know
that sounds crazy but when you see these
socks you will understand that is a
woman's collection I'm waiting to open
it I want to I want to put them on the
feet that stands on right now they have
that little logo on it which is how you
determine what's up can I finally reach
these boxes are dope and which socks are
not I love stands for years like I've
had I've been wearing stands for so long
ever since my friend told me about them
a long time ago and they came to us they
want to sponsor the bad guys and I'm so
freaking excited guys right now go to
Stan's comm check out their holiday
collection can check out their regular
collection Rihanna has a line with them
they are the [ __ ] so thank you Stan's my
mom Rihanna
we will talk more finally later well
like what are you gonna do you're gonna
wear your nice easy sneakers or whatever
your nice shoes menu gets on our sad
socks
what are you alright I'm gonna put them
on some waiting finally finally although
it's my turn oh yeah Oh feel that okay
anyway we're cozy for this week's
podcast I like honestly this is this is
my life outfit this is my life uniform
so today we want to read each other's
palms and potentially our faces to get
some fun stuff from Funspot
do some fun stuff with you we can hold
hands the whole podcast well we can't we
can do not that wait her you know hold
hands holding hands challenge where you
hold each other's hands your reaction
just now is my reaction to a lot of
challenges on the internet like what it
what is the challenge there is no
challenge no it's like interesting stuff
and I've always wanted to do this like
in a video or something in the past and
I've just never done it and I felt like
it made more sense to make it like a
podcast because we can do each other's
you know yeah for sure and we can also
have a conversation about what our
are saying into it maybe they're not
saying anything you never know what and
if you're listening along I'm sorry or
watching the water then you can also
read your own palm and then you won't
have to google it yourself because we'll
have done it for you and - e110
listening to this podcast actually knows
about reading palms and indulge us it
knows like actual facts and what they're
doing
just please a don't be offended by our
ignorance and be maybe comment below on
what we are what we need to do better
all right maybe I'm already assuming
we're going to [ __ ] up okay so we have
some literature here this is a diagram
that shows the different main lines that
you were to read in someone's palm so
I'll read yours you have to do your
dominant hand your dominant hand so
that's my Radian actually there are
theories that say you can also get more
out of reading your non-dominant hand
but we're going to go with the dominant
okay so the life line the life line is
the one that goes from the inside of
your pointer finger around your thumb
and back like down sorta to your wrist
so we are going to read that one really
quickly alone I was like down yeah it
goes like should go from your finger
down to your right there like around the
thumb yeah
the lifeline tells you about your
subjects quality of life along yakked
you got like line in it is a sign that
things are good I don't even have one
just give me your dominant hand look at
how deep that is dog [ __ ] damn that is
deep okay Julian so Tom looks like three
four but like three really deep dark
lies yeah a lot of my left hand is not
the same at all yeah your lifeline on
your left hand like doesn't show up have
a lifeline over there
mine mine is a giant split in the middle
of it is what a long deep lifeline is a
sign that things are good a faint
lifeline suggests that there was a lack
of energy or adventure and a complete
absence of life on suggest that you have
a lot of
daddy some people don't have a lifeline
at all yeah I don't live on this well
but on my right hand I do but um if
there are breaks um yeah mine's like no
wait look at that like right in the
middle it's split yours like has a fork
into - yeah okay so small breaks in the
line are indicative of past traumas or
major losses moderate amount of breaks
can be a sign of someone burning the
candle at both ends
so maybe your burning the candle at both
ends Jenna I know yours is like yours is
a good lifeline but then another one
forms out of it I would say you're
pretty healthy what does it say about
that doesn't say if there's a fork in
the road mine's a literal fork it just
splits off into a snake tongue what's
mine yours is like a Mike Sherman I
think lifeline can you see this like it
goes all the way down like onto your
wrist yeah it's pretty good I like a
solid like oh my god I have a good life
finder damn you're gonna live forever
that's what that means I know that I
literally is you're more you what it
meant you know your infernal
not more oh my god guys Julian's
immortal oh stop calling me wait what
are some other things that your life
line could look like and what do they
mean well I mean all about break those
breaks I mean here wasn't in the
Romanian and major lines headline life
line okay curves around yeah I mean
evaluate the life line let's see if the
light line is long and deep you have
good health and stamina curvy life line
means there's an abundance of energy a
line that runs close to the thumb do you
have that no okay if there are multiple
life lines okay
that means you have extra strength and
vitality but the other one says the
opposite does it not know that says if
there's a bunch of breaks in one if you
have multiple lines which this is
multiple lines as it's forming a new one
you have strength and vitality is that
what it means or does it mean that I
also exists in another dimension that's
what I'm hoping it means I'm living a
double are you gonna just take every
reading we have inside
that it means you're in a yes yes I am
alright fine I will never give up I'm on
a relentless quest to be in another
dimension at the same time I would say
that you have helped my job because this
looks like you have two lifelines right
one right there and then it veers off
yeah but that could mean trauma and it
could know cuz trauma is there this
breaks and I don't see any break
oh I understand you got it yeah it's
like a dotted line that means trauma oh
do you have helping my god it's like
hairy right they're not hairy so lit how
is mine so dark it looks like someone
drew it on you okay apologies in advance
for those listening to the podcast is
probably not really interesting but you
know sometimes you get what you get and
you give it a gift yeah but you can also
look at your own hand it's fun follow
allah follow along everyone class on
page your hand okay to is the headline
okay so this is the line that goes
pretty much directly through the middle
of your hands the middle it's the middle
one that goes it's not up by your
fingers and it's not the one near your
thumb it's the middle while you're
making an L on her forehead you take
right in the middle that out right there
and you go exactly the opposite in your
hand that's the headline so let's see
your headline all right a long headline
that stretches across the palm can be an
indicator that of one person who thinks
too much about things over analyzing
problems again again I mean mine should
warn fantastically along then so yours
is you have multiple headlines look it
it goes like oh but yeah you have it
what's this I don't know I got two
different Lonnie lines okay I need to
see your hand my hand is like a paper
mache like creepy swinging projects your
headline instead of going all the way
across it kind of falls down to your
palms or the bottom or bump yeah oh my
target card instead comes down yeah so
let's see what that means a short
headline can indicate one moves too
quickly a curved headline is a sign that
someone is romantic creative and
idealistic that is not me yeah well I am
NOT romantic or creative you're what
yeah I'm you're creative
any romantic and kidding that Kermit has
this one a broken headline in contrast
suggest ones is suffering from
nervousness and mental exhaustion
current headline is so broken you look
at Kermit's paw and you just see one
broken head and even though you don't
have lines ah ah okay so we what's mine
though
mine's long and choice is ah long and
strong maybe no it's not that long it's
song instant stops about 3/4 of the way
through your palm and it's really dark
and it's not very curved it's pretty
straight it's a straight but it's is it
long would you say that's long no cuz
look how it stops here okay a short line
can me I mean I move too quickly oh my
god the zoo is right that is you but it
is a short line it's like a bullet
yes oh my god that's so funny making
decisions without fully sorting out
their implications ah thank you
palm reading this is accurate is far
it's been so validated like that's not
even a lie that's so real it's Julian in
a nutshell let's check out the other
literature on the headline I wouldn't
exactly call this literature but in
literature I got it from the library no
you got it from the internet from the
library a straight headline
realistically logical and organized ah
headline begins at the lifeline mmm is
that how it is mine does yeah
that means this person is strong-willed
ooh
tight your shows too though oh no it
doesn't they kind of just like start at
all they start at the same point that I
think that's what that means no I
thought that meant like the headline
comes out of the lifeline they don't
start at the same point this one just
breaks off but maybe I don't know a
broken headline
do you've a broken headline no you're
just a curb okay so that's pretty that's
pretty straightforward pretty
straightforward what is the broken
headline mean just in case someone's
listening and they have a broken
headline they want to know what it means
oh you got a you got a CO CO doctor
right now
broken headline indicates
inconsistencies and thought crosses in
the line may mean that vital and crucial
decisions have a very
important effect on the person's fate
chains or donuts in the headline
indicate personal conflict or emotional
difficult like circles yeah lava so if
you have circles in your headline that
means you you're you're tortured you're
a tortured soul maybe well look at this
and see how there's like a little circle
there that might be what a donut is mmm
looks exactly like a donut my my like
hands like your lines are so clear and
mine have all these like little tiny
lines all over them that's wild
I just feel like mine look sort of like
scarves it looks like that dry it looks
like they're drawing after they drew the
red lines I it's crazy how deep my lines
are okay moving on headline is done what
else you got heart line what are you
doing going into the chat up later it's
not literature it's a page we printed
off the internet the heart line so the
heart line is above the head line the
heart line goes from the pointer finger
and kind of stays atop your hand and
goes to the pinky or just outside the
pinky so it's the top button so it's
this one yeah
mine doesn't completely go to my my
pointer finger though it kind of just
picks up in the middle of my hand mine
goes in between my first finger and my
middle finger okay let me read it the
heart line gives insight to one's
emotions a long straight heart line
indicates that someone who is that's
about as rational and considerate a long
heart line that arcs upward in contrast
suggests that a person is openly and
unapologetically driven by his or her
passions and desires geez are you
calling me selfish hand no you just
think for yourself and you probably an
unapologetically this doesn't arc upward
this we're talking about this right yeah
sort of does this one it goes not head
what it likes stop so does mine it stops
but then there's like it Forks off into
those three different ones okay so let's
see what that means a short straight
line suggests that someone isn't
particularly driven by thoughts of
romance and let's see a curve or lack of
curve
makes all the difference okay hmm why
don't you just tell it what what all the
means yeah I am I'm looking I'm trying
to figure out it it is called the heart
line right all right the Heartland
starts below the index finger it means
that you are picky when it comes to love
that's all day specific an absent heart
line indicates an individual who is
ruled by logic rather than emotion a
faint line shows who a person who is
aloof in places little importance on
emotions a strange number line indicates
someone who is not particularly
concerned with romance and if the heart
line is straight in parallel to the head
line indicates the individual has a good
handle on their emotions a broken heart
line with or a heart line with the
smaller lines cross and can indicate
emotional trauma that's me you have
emotional trauma I have that too though
mine breaks off and goes up yeah you
drive a little one that goes up what all
my poor babies traumatize me - oh wow
one one one's got corn on so much an
emotional trauma I don't know about this
one this one's kind of a myth yeah so
far the headline those like really
accurate yeah okay number four the
girdle of Venus oh you nasty and you
need Venus okay okay so this is
basically if you can imagine like a
smiley face um encapsulating your middle
finger and your ring finger on your palm
on your palm like a little like if your
ring finger middle finger oh the two
eyes there's a smiley face kind of
semicircle blue okay short line above
the heart line so this comes right above
the hard line I don't have this line
yeah I don't either
this is absent this can indicate a wound
up and nervous person you nervous I
think that's what this means
so not everyone has this line
okay so that's good and we wound up and
nervous yes good but if you are you got
that girdle girl yeah girl you got that
girdle the girdle of Venus enhances the
subjects emotional and sensual
receptivity to his or her environment
right that's nice
alright number five show me your girdle
number five so this is basically if your
pinkie was a line and it went through
your palm and it goes all the way to
your wrist it's a straight line right by
your pinkie right yeah if you have that
I have like two feathery faint lines
like that but they're by no means lines
they're just feathery like it looks like
almost like scratches they're so faint I
have this so you have one hot one is
that this one it's about was five okay
what's it called it's called the Apollo
line or the Sun line oh your Apollo is
[ __ ] that's an indicator of success a
sign that someone is creative
self-confident and extremely capable of
falling through on a plan of action damn
it I want an Apollo line so I have that
which means [ __ ] basically I'm amazing
at least one of us has won the Apollo or
Sun line is a failure my hand even says
so yeah interesting
okay lack thereof means just don't worry
that's what it says it says that lacking
this line does not reflect one success
so don't worry if you don't have one
well I feel worried okay number six the
mercury line or health line this is just
a little more towards the outside of
your hand on the scene I have no such
thing hmm was it what does it mean it's
it's I don't even know it means it's
about your communication skills so if
it's broken
mmm-hmm you have possible illnesses and
friends their loved one those of loved
ones that have coming on that does make
sense okay it okay present a strong
presence in this line can indicate
someone as good with their communication
skills and it runs directly from your
pinky DRS is the same last language back
towards the or towards the outside of
your palm we're I don't have one of
those I don't have any
I don't have that either what's this
number seven line all it runs like from
your ring or middle finger straight down
to your wrist so it's like ring finger
right in the middle of your palm I have
one that runs more Center like from my
middle finger down to my but it doesn't
start here it needs to start there no
it's just a line that runs down the
middle of your palm oh okay oh yeah yeah
I literally have one right there I have
that one that one's a big one yeah what
does it mean this is your hide to one's
life path okay an indication of
obstacles that may be faced educational
and occupational choices accomplishments
and how content individual is with their
life the faint line also tells us about
duty and responsibility so let's look at
the favor okay let's go the faint line
starts joined to the lifeline what's a
life lining in middle or top if you let
it on the floor I think it's the oh it's
the one by your thumb that's yeah first
one if it starts with your lifeline if
it starts joined to the lifeline that's
crazy
this indicates a self-made individual
who develops aspirations early on on
life [ __ ] do you ever know I do how does
it start with your lifeline it doesn't
collide yeah you're totally like breaks
and changes of direction in the Fate
line can indicate many changes in life
from external forces I have some mm-hmm
okay hmm keep going um a deep faint line
means that the person's life will
strongly be controlled by fate well
individuals have the Fate line well I
definitely have a fate yeah this is a
strong deep failing yeah it is look at
minds in comparison to the other ones
though it's like just as prominent yeah
except for this one this headline or
whatever the top one is heart line is
pretty deep interesting but my fate line
is just as deep as my life line and my
headline yeah
that's crazy okay well that's that's all
the literature of the marriage line but
I need to know more about my fate that's
all it says okay like feathers off at
the bottom we have something I got some
more several several light lines
indicate several romances wait on which
line the Fate line several light wise
yes or not one defined line but several
light lines I mean I have some up
towards the top Julian's like looking at
me like you guys romances going on
no I do not blame yourself I do not um
strong and clear lines indicate marriage
marriage like justice fans just says
marriage
numerous overlapping lines indicate
affairs boy I don't have numerous
overlapping my mind that meet but don't
cross show children that will be born
these are very different things yeah
fusing me but don't cross so like these
these ones that come in hmm I have like
one two three
but then there's no that's the same line
three four so you're telling me I'm
thirty years old not about to have four
babies I didn't write this stuff
quadruplets boy guys I'm gonna be on bed
rest for about two years
quadruplets working the lines you've a
fork yeah at the bottom the back of the
hand where's the back of my fork in the
line towards like the bottom of me yeah
indicate a long engagement a fork at the
end towards the palm means separation
with or without divorce fork at the end
so if it Forks towards your hand yeah if
it force away from your hand that means
you're committed wait is it like are we
talking about left and right yeah so
forks towards my thumb yeah so forks
right here see that means that mean that
means you're committed for a long
engagement and if it forth in the middle
it would mean you're gonna have a
divorce
oh so you have the right fork I don't
have a fork at all wait yeah I do I have
the engagement for it hey a long
engagement
what do you say I say long engagement
let's get engaged and never married long
engaged the longest wait is open I want
to know like real talk what's like the
Guinness World Record like the longest
engagement because I think that's
hilarious I'm looking at them right now
we should get engaged with no intention
of ever getting married just to see how
long we can be engaged let's see the
world's longest engagement sixty-seven
years
Howard in the Audi comm next time your
Phoenix okay let me see the world's
coldest feet okay that's a long time we
really you're gonna take me to a [ __ ]
list
[ __ ] you we should try and break it okay
I'm done it would piss the intern off to
no end I love it all right you know what
you have to let it be known that years
the longest engagement ever not getting
married
checking my sauces hey why is my phone
like the worst thing ever I don't know
why you use Siri honestly what did she
ever tell about you unbelievable
calm down I'm looking up engagements oh
okay here we go
no these all suck don't don't even
bother it's at 67 years let's go with
that but only and Gandhi's alive I don't
like that he's alive he's very well he
is not rocketing we know he's not alone
he's not because if you were alive is
that it that's that's the literature I
have I don't know we can the Fate line
the marriage line the fame line what's
this Syria Fame line okay if this line
if visible starts at the base of the
hand and moves its way up below the ring
finger so like that
no do you know where your ring finger is
Julie alone didn't say mine I want to
let me just read it okay okay Lita the
fame line influences the social rewards
of success this line if visible starts
at the base of the hand
and moves its way up to below the ring
finger running parallel to the Fate line
so it would be a straight up-and-down
line in the middle of your hand towards
your ring finger I don't have that you
don't have that mo and their
characteristics of the fame line to look
for a missing Fame line indicates that
one's future fame must be looked for in
other areas of the palm the individual
may still be successful but prefer to do
without public acclaim
if the fame line is strong and clear
this indicates distinction and
satisfaction with your life's work if
the fame line is broken repeatedly it's
an indication of the ups and downs of
social recognition a fan line that
travels straight to the ring finger
shows a person is likely to have fame in
the arts if it starts at the headline
and runs through the heart line this
shows hard work and success late in life
a separation at the end of the fame line
becoming to smaller lines indicates that
success may be dubious and value a faint
line that ends beneath the ring finger
in a star or triangle how I hope
something that ding fam'ly is a star
triangle on to the ring finger tobe
crazy did the other I don't
it shows the ocular success awaits in
the fine arts field acting singing
dancing if it ends beneath the ring
finger in a square this indicates a
kindly patron that's crazy so much a
[ __ ] star on their palm but like I
can see that these lines are really fine
and tiny like they can make a star
that's wild all right several wait those
a different one you didn't do the money
line oh yeah I want to do either of
those alright first I want to read my um
my life what you call your foot palm
your foot palm are you absolutely can
eat my foot palm because it's covered
with a Stan's sock that was painful for
her that was painful and I'm sorry but I
had to do it I had to hit him with it
what do you call your foot pump what is
the foot pump called on the bottom of
your foot I don't know the ball you're
fine do you know that's a part of your
foot pole
you're asking me to give you a real word
for what is the but the palm of your
foot Tom but guys don't read your foot
palms instead just cover your feet up
with Stan's socks because Stan's socks
are amazing they allow you to express
your creativity with every single pair
of sock you buy they have turned the
world's most boring accessory into
something that's really cool and
artistic they have so many differences I
mean like the designs are crazy they
have a subsection for everything you'd
ever want they have lines for put your
favorite sports teams they have like all
sorts of themes in their socks it's
amazing their headquarters in San
Clemente in Southern California and they
were founded in 2009 and they're now
sold in over 40 countries Stan's ignited
a movement of art and self-expression
that is now drawing athletes performance
and iconic influencers to the brand and
myself included I love Stan's so much
some of their new and noteworthy
collections that you guys should check
out our Star Wars collections the
women's socks that utilize Japanese silk
is that what this is that what those are
these are called a running light a
casual line [ __ ] new lines from Rihanna
ah mom girl they have legends
collections and like I said future NBA
Hall of Famers sports and then they have
things like biggie
Johnny Cash a Tribe Called Quest and
Tupac themed socks like they have really
really great [ __ ] in there a product is
top of the line top top top of the line
go to Stan's calm right now and check
out Stan's socks the uncommon thread and
when you're done with it with Stan's and
you want to get a little onesie in maybe
a beer pong shirt beer pong Cup shirt or
a target practice shirt or an ugly
Christmas sweater or a Christmas suit go
to tipsy elves everyone needs an ugly
Christmas sweater or onesie this time
here if you want bragging rights for the
most talked about sweater go to tipsy
elves
we got onesies and I can't really wear
mine right now because it's a green
onesie and we're on a green screen but
I'm wearing it the bottom like it's even
look at mine and it
there's four pockets the new two of them
have zippers and oh there's one thing I
gotta tell you guys about Charlotte
there's a peepee zipper so you can
zipper it from bottom to top this is
Julien complaining I can undo this ever
just a pin so you have to under your
whole onesie to pee like that is I can't
do the same but thank you thank you that
was really well thought out to tea elves
I mean I've never seen that in a onesie
no neither am i right now all the ding
family can get 20% off when you get a
tipsy elves come and use jayjay at
checkout 20% off site-wide get yourself
an ugly Christmas sweater or onesie
whatever it is with you Adam
and then we'll party about it read each
other's sponsor you sponsors wonderful
sponsors so in my family we stopped
doing presents a long time ago like will
well get my nice presents obviously but
it's just easier for everyone the family
we're just like one Christmas we're all
like you guys want to just do no
presents we're like yeah totally and
then it takes a lot of the stress away
from everybody yeah especially because
we all live in different places and we
have to travel but my mom and I will
still always sort of like give each
other little stuff
Sneaky's like socks like this is the
perfect no presents present and that's
that's the best thing about Stan's is
like it's taking something that's so
easy and oftentimes written off as a
lazy gift and makes it really special
right but that's like that's me and my
mom's thing like when we went to Japan
or like we go to London I'm like I just
get her a pair of socks yeah cuz it's
like I can't help but get you something
because I love you but no presence you
know this is a women's travel collection
I want to see what this one's I mean
these are ridiculously saw and a holy
[ __ ] that's deep it's so on um but yeah
for those also I highly recommend
convincing your family to do no presence
if you're if you're like an adult and
you're going to all the holidays just
convince your family to do no presents
it's sewn that makes everything a lot
less weird really all right um not to
read more my mom would love these socks
and so we have to get the machine some
money one I wanted to yeah do you think
girl
I was doing it dad hopefully I have a
big my dad talked about yeah
socks dad okay this line is on a direct
indicator of assessing material wealth
yo can you chill with that dick zipper
over there oh my god a summer I
apologize welcome back um I swear to God
again this line is not a dick Juliet not
a direct indicator of assessing material
wealth it represents the Bears skill in
acquiring riches as well as keeping some
indicators of how to achieve this the
characteristics of the money line are it
runs from the base of the thumb to below
the index finger ending in a star it
shows a natural talent for money-making
does it be someone's hand that has one
of these so-called stars
what is that star I have no money line
well I don't have anything even in that
vicinity my point towards my index
finger actually it just has like four
lines I have it and that's and that's it
that's it I got four lines four lines
four lines four lines for a line I got
four lines and that's it okay a line
running from the base of the thumb to
the little finger why don't they just
say pinky it's called the pinky oh I
don't have that at all do you live
across the whole hand no I have I've
three and four lines nothing else okay
that that indicates wealth acquired know
is this a star boy no is that a star Oh
Julia's just fighting like tiny obscure
lines on his wrist I might add but is it
though it probably might be is no um
can I tell you some before I go on that
in like middle school or whatever there
was some how this got started as a rumor
that if you like go like that with your
thumb like you just crunch your thumb
down and then you look at this inner
part of your thumb and you read how many
likes that
how many kids you're gonna have accurate
is [ __ ] that sounds like something you
do in school
alright that's made up because mine
doesn't really have a line also it's
your hand and and if you and if your
hand had zero of those lines and you
went and had a bunch of kids who's wrong
well that's yeah well all of this is a
little you know it is what is it out
there but like I believe a lot of it but
I believe much I'm not a hundred percent
I mean yet it's like anything else I
mean I think the astrology you take it
with a grain of salt but I take this
with it a shaker of salt I mean it's it
was only what it said I had a Furious
personality that I don't really give
thought to things and I just kind of do
them
that's very me but at the same time
that's kind of a broad personality trait
and I feel like that can Julian yeah
Julian no I'm just saying like Julian
I'm very accurate you are Aries is [ __ ]
you are a tornado okay and your hand
just said the same thing alright but I'm
I all I'm saying
alls I'm saying here is that it might
have just been a coincidence like white
palm reading might be not as accurate as
one would like to think no of course but
it's it's it's an art form
people do it it isn't necessarily I
never sent always true but even if you
went for like a psychic reading or a
tarot card reading like you can't go
back there and be like you said this and
this didn't work like you take it with a
level of cynicism
I mean oh yeah and also like I'm pretty
sure people who are you know psychics
are or anything of the sort
don't claim to be like I know the future
I know what's going to have a little fun
in that so it's not like that's also
opening people yourselves up to serious
liability yeah yeah there was I forget I
was watching those videos I wanted a
psychic you've been to a psychic yeah I
have a bunch of time and you've done the
email one to a while ago that one was
incredible to do a psychic we should go
do you didn't do that I thought you did
I thought you had I had an email no you
wanted me to and I never did it you were
doing for all your friends and I never
yeah well your chinami trencher in
really weird places and i was like dude
you gotta email these peopie remember
that's like when i first met it was
great um we actually we've been
discussing with someone a potential
medium to come on the podcast which we
could work on having happen yeah but
I've never gone honestly be reading I'd
honestly be less interested in a medium
like doing medium stuff and I'd be more
interested in asking like meta question
about being amazing that's my reason
question hundred percent only reason I
would ever want to have a medium on the
podcast is to literally pick his brain
about meat being a median being a medium
and talking to the dead or whatever you
want to call like I wouldn't want him to
have like do like do readings while he's
in here or theory you could immune decay
I just want to hear what he what he
knows
yeah me too well no but hold on it's
time for some he I support you stop it
you [ __ ] nasty she took a cardboard
thing in like shaved his arm with it um
Sylvia Browne I think her name is I was
watching him I was watching a video of
people being like she's a fraud she's a
phony and like this woman was going on
television shows whatever her last name
is ant remember it um she was going on
television shows and like telling people
to leave you know their sick loved ones
in the hospital or like take them home
yeah like really [ __ ] up intense life
decisions because a lot of the reason
why well you got to be careful I say but
I feel like a lot of the reason why
people um dismiss psychics and stuff is
because it's you can't prove it
obviously and a lot of the people that
seek out psychics and things like that
are doing some really trying times in
their lives yeah like they need an
answer and you know kind of take what
they can get yeah it's like you can pray
to God if you know imagine your your
loved one is sick and you just you need
to know what to do you don't know what
to do you're really freaking out and
sometimes it just gives you the comfort
of someone saying like you know this
this is what you should get yeah or or
to have the belief that it's coming from
some sort of higher power you know so
that's what there's a lot of criticism
of
psychics that it's fake or whatever but
a lot of these people are really [ __ ]
like just looking for answers like
really seeking answers and so it would
she like got in a lot of trouble because
she was telling people to do things very
definitively and it came back to bite
her in the ass yeah that sounds like it
would ruffle feathers like that that
style as well yeah I mean it's also
taking advantage of the goodwill of
people who are giving you the light of
day to hear your opinions on things it's
just really sad like I like hurts my
heart yeah I mean I get it I get it I
get why that's wrong but I also get why
people do it because in any scope or any
arena of life professional or otherwise
there is always a subset of people who
[ __ ] it up for everyone else yeah in
anything because I totally believe that
there are real psychics there are real
mediums there are real people with real
like Tallis yeah gifts just even if it's
a strong level of intuition or all of
them agree completely I also understand
that those people are human beings and
they I don't know anybody that can
perfectly hone those skills yeah you
know I think only by sometimes when some
of people comparing that it's perfect
right oh yes yeah or that they can do
things that really is just not even
possible
yeah that's crazy terrorism it is wild
it is about but I mean honestly if you
guys are into having a medium come on
the podcast let us know and we'll pursue
that because we can probably get that
done or if you want someone else or you
know you have an idea in this sort of
arena what what you know for a guest I
think that could be a fun interesting
podcast because I would totally go into
it with I just want to learn I just want
to hear someone else's life experience
who does this with their time that's it
like that's as simple as it needs to be
I feel like I have so many questions for
that person I mean also after our hotel
podcast I've got me thinking for sure
yeah yeah that [ __ ] that [ __ ] come to us
wait so you've never had a psychic
reading ever oh ah it's fun never had to
say you're reading never I had fun with
the psychic twins they were fun too when
they did that hmm it's cool they were
doing this like loopy drawing writing
thing while they were doing is [ __ ]
gorgeous
whatever anyways um travel line I don't
have drawn the line by for life nothing
else travel lines are a major indication
of the trips taken throughout your life
that have had or will have a penetrating
impact on your life they can also
indicate your desire to travel some
things to look for in relation to the
travel lines are the Travel line that
intersects the life line what it doesn't
tell you what the Travel line is and
whatever we're six was the chart was the
chart doesn't apply to this letter mine
all right mirror lines minor lines minor
lines they include lines of opposition
intuition escape and influence yeah but
I have like so many minor lines how are
you supposed to even I don't know it
looks like it my hand looks like the
crumpled piece of paper these are so
crazy okay look at these these are
community Q&A that's someone answered if
my health line is faint does it indicate
poor health if your health line is faint
it indicates that you will have few or
no health problems in your life wait so
that does that mean that you you gonna
be sick
maybe I am sick I see like if you have a
deep dark line it means get tested for
celiac disease cuz boy you allergic to
that wheat I have a gluten free line yo
he's your gluten life would that be
crazy though if you had a gluten line on
your hand and you went to the doctor
window and you're a kid he was like let
me see boil em see ooh
society to tell you you can't eat bagels
right now however again um what does it
mean if the lifeline is cut and joined
again what see if there are multiple
lifelines multiple life lines indicate
extra strength and vitality a break in
the lifeline means a sudden change in
lifestyle or interruption
if the lifeline is broken on both hands
this may indicate a serious illness or
injury circles in the line or a chain
line indicate that the person is
susceptible to many health problems and
that their life may take them in many
different directions
again I have four lines so yeah and it's
not broken mine has like a circle in
that one tight that's crazy
can you really depend on palm-reading
no more often than not a palm reader
will make a vague enough statement so
that they could apply to virtually
anyone or the person getting this
reading will twist logic to make it
apply to them if they want to believe do
not rely on reading yeah although it is
fun and exciting to try see that's good
to know yeah that's what we're talking
about what do I do if I'm left-handed
yet I do things right-handed your
dominant hand would be whatever hand you
use more often judging by the
information you gave you are either
right-handed or imitation boy figured I
don't know what handed you are everybody
does stuff both their hands unless
you're like unless you're the person
who's like writing an essay with your
left hand you get tired so you switch to
your right hand which doesn't exist I
mean listen to this next question how do
I determine the first letter of my
future husband's name the letter which
forms on your left hand thumb determines
your husband's name eight people found
that helpful and eight people found that
not helpful the letter which forms on
your left hand thumb what does that mean
that forms on your thumb okay see now
it's getting ridiculous I don't know
what that means what part of your thumb
I don't have any letter on my thumb well
it may be the minutes cuz you're not
gonna have a husband where's my thumb
what does that mean that forms on your
left hand like the rest of this has been
so specific and then that's just like
others lettering your thumb that's agree
what the [ __ ] that's really odd yeah I'm
like okay my brain hurts from that what
do branch is going downward from the
heart line to cross the head line mean
heart line head line okay so if you have
lines that cross down from the top one
to the middle one branches are not the
best sign as they ended
attachments attachments never come to
our expectations and sadness brings
stress it may relate to emotions over
taking thought process or emotions
clouding that thought process okay why
does my palm have four lines this is
usually it's me it's hard to say because
there's no description of these lines
having less lines is generally better
but the question is too vague to be more
specific I like how these people are
actually asking these questions like on
this thread yeah that's well to me man
well how did you guys do in your palm
reading said you did you pass are you
are you high V are you nervous are you
I'm high my love are you divorced over
here divorced looking in my thumb for it
to reveal some letter to me what parties
I'm so angry there's like the most
ridiculous thing I've ever heard but as
if you're gonna look down at your thumb
and it's gonna have like a W on it or
some [ __ ] what just says is that John
John so yeah you're like an
eight-year-old and you're like hello I'm
looking for John John I'm supposed to
marry you someday when I'm a full adult
oh so I mean but that's that's what I
mean like yeah I'm there I'm there and
then that happened you dropped off the
club I'm not there anymore like I said
have you ever read the about fingers
like if your ring finger is longer than
your index finger I've read stuff out
that yeah but that's impossible
what do you mean that's impossible it's
impossible for me because it's not I
don't get what you're saying my ring
finger is not longer than my middle
finger I want to look it up so you're
what do you mean I just mean it's
impossible because it's not how my hands
are but if someone else's hands are
different than that it's just how your
hands are you're so ridiculous okay it's
impossible alright I could pull it maybe
if i crack that knuckle I'll pop it out
of socket you know you never know what
pop socket means boy okay so if your put
your hand out it's out
which hand though both okay it make it
relax
no wait relax if your ring finger is
longer than your index finger so if
you're looking at your hand flat yeah
and your ring finger is longer than your
index finger people have a ring finger
longer than the index finger tend to be
charming and irresistible to some at
least get charmed hold on I'm trying -
yours is not chiming your met your index
finger is longer
that's my nail yeah mmm Julian do you
know the difference between a finger
nail and a finger no what's the
difference between those two things I
don't know well you tell me because you
think my index finger is longer than my
ring finger yes maybe it's just the
angle you know I was trying to read this
I had girl do you think huh um okay
they're charming and irresistible
they're the ones who can talk about them
talk themselves out of any situation
they're aggressive and excellent problem
solvers they tend to be incredibly
compassionate and are often scientist
engineer soldiers and crossword puzzle
masters that is me [ __ ] have you ever
seen me do a crossword puzzle alright
Julian has tapped out of this
conversation he's zipping himself up
into a onesie I have I've seen you do
puzzles you're good at puzzles no
crossword puzzles that is a puzzle isn't
it he hates you so much he has no face
alright if your face if your index
finger is longer than your ring finger
you love solitude in which to work and
accomplish things
it doesn't necessarily indicate
introversion they're very goal-oriented
and don't like to be disturbed they
appreciate what they have but often
hunger for more and if your ring finger
and index finger are even they're
peace-loving and conflict avoiding types
people will even ring out what the [ __ ]
with even gradient index tickling a well
organized and what nothing but to get
along with every
they're faithful and relationships
tender and caring partners but beware
seas have a fiery core oh boy like the
magma in the center of the earth while
suppressed in the normal day-to-day
activities can be dangerous if Unleashed
they might be peaceniks what does that
mean peaceniks but please stay on our
good side stop shaking my hand let me
see your hand
well good the media yeah your ring
finger is longer we're the same pull
Donegan area no stop please stop doing
that what happened to you you just all
of a suddent like we lost Julian
he just went insane who's Julian I don't
know I got I got excited about my once
bit pull my sleeve no I don't want to
pull your sling
Wow someone saved me
I have four lines okay and four lines
critic dude it looks like someone just
drew on your hand four lines and they're
like up that's it that's his palm pop
all right let me done here Julian no I'm
just
I've lost really no I I'm I'm here I'm
you see it's fine I'm here it's not fine
what's fine I mean I'll boil my lines
all 10 of yours it's all fine
I'm like 70 yeah yeah yeah totally no
but let us not you guys did on the palm
readings and do you have any last words
before we in the podcast no but you may
give me crazy
I like these socks in this onesie and
this is my life outfit for every outfit
alright guys thanks think family love
you we love you so much and tell us in
the comments what you hit what your
palms mean because I'm interested to
know and let us know what our palms mean
right don't we want anything our palms -
yeah I do
or your fall palm if you know how to
read foot palms let Julian know because
he's very interested what is it foot
palm home um a foam
that make sense to put PLO t no put foam
no foam foot palm F ALM foam the link on
the soccer Sawant Bom Bom Bom
all right everybody fellas value by